and finally new rule if Humanity can
impose rules on Warfare let's do
something really ambitious let's try
them on high school because our public
schools are no longer safe for the
teachers a 15-year-old in Houston this
year sucker punched his teacher for
confiscating his phone after screaming
give me my phone I told you to give me
my phone hey Sprint you may have
a new
spokesperson
in Florida a high school student beat a
teacher's aid unconscious for taking his
Nintendo
switch hitting the teacher I used to get
sent to the principal's office for
rolling my eyes go online you can see
endless videos of this stuff of kids
threatening and punching teachers what
is this Jet
Blue what have we let our schools turn
into
a third of teachers in America say
they've been harassed or threatened and
one in seven in this country has been
physically attacked 2023 kicked off with
the story of a six-year-old boy taking a
gun to school in Newport News Virginia
shooting his teacher and then declaring
I shot that
dead which would be a cool last line for
a Mickey Spain
novel but a six-year-old the librarian
at the school added some context to the
story saying every day in every one of
our schools teachers students and other
staff members are being hurt every day
they're hit they're bitten they're
beaten no wonder 50% of teachers Express
a desire to quit or transfer to
something less dangerous like walking
Joe Biden's
dog no wonder 86% of public schools have
a a teacher shortage because 20 years
ago if you said American High School
people pictured
this now they picture
this only 8% of schools say it's easy to
even find bus drivers a few weeks ago
some Oklahoma
middle schoolers were acting up on the
bus so the driver pulled over and said
he wasn't going to go anywhere until
they quieted down so the kids
immediately obeyed because he was the
adult I'm joking of
course they went even more
batshit down no sit down and when school
officials reviewed video of the incident
all those kids were punished I'm joking
again of course the kids were given
counseling and the driver was fired
fired arrested and charg with child
abuse and that is the root of our
problem moms and dads used to have the
backs of teachers and authority figures
but now their precious progeny can never
do anything wrong so it's made education
impossible and I know you're saying Bill
what do you know about it you never had
kids I know
jealous but I know this a teacher today
looks out every morning and sees 25
phones distracting 25 kids undeterred by
any authority to pay attention or even
be civil and each kid represented by the
high-powered legal defense team of mom
and
dad no I'm sure there are parents seeing
this and saying that's not us and this
isn't our experience true not all
schools are violent and scary but they
are all diploma Mills that allow
students to graduate without demanding
the kids no basic
25 years ago George W bush asked is
our children
learning well it's only gotten worse
only 33% of us children can read at a
level of proficiency if you're attending
an American High School now that's about
onethird
so I'm not surprised that homeschooling
is America's fastest growing form of
education and not just with weirdo
Christian families who make their
daughters wear a
bonnet to millions of parents anything
is better now than public education and
that includes Catholic school you know
in 1970 only
2.7% of the kids who went to Catholic
School were not Catholic now it's 22%
yeah Catholic School e8th graders are
two full grade levels above public
school kids because their school isn't a
safe space for off they're told
no you can't be on your phone here and
your pronouns are shut up and sit
down how up is this country that
to get a no education now you
have to go to the place that's
completely based on
what we
need what we need in this country is a
chain of non Catholic Catholic schools
and since many celebrities have opened
their own schools oh yeah that's how
serious we are about education in
America we let celebrities do it LeBron
has one George Clooney Pitbull Tony
Bennett had one Andre ausy
Kanye had
one well now I'm thinking of doing it
and opening Bill Mars Catholic
School it's like traditional catholic
school just without the religion and the
molesting at Bill mahs Catholic school
we do school old
school with a curriculum called School
classic rule one no phones all day no
exceptions not just so the kids aren't
distracted when they're trying to learn
but also because it forces hovering
parents to leave them the alone for
eight hours you're the parent not their
probation
officer other rules include no making up
a disorder that allows your kid to get
more time on the test we call that by
its original name
cheating no participation ribbons no
turning in anything late no vaping no
emotional support animals and of course
if a student doesn't maintain a c
average or higher absolutely no sex with
the
teacher